So first off, what might
the signature of this look like?
>> So I think we're still working
with this check out method, but
now we're specifying a post
condition of the method.
So the signature is still patron,
checkout,
a loanable item as as an argument and
the implied argument of patron, but
the the post condition is
what we're worried about.
>> Okay, so
that raises an interesting point.
So we just had an example where we were
expressing some of the properties
of the check out process.
This case, having to do with kids.
>> Okay.
>> In fact, you could have any number of
constraints about a particular class or
a particular operation.
What they mean is its as if you
were 'anding' all those together.
So, this must be true, and this must
be true, and this must be true.
Well, the thing about
the kids must be true, but
it's only going to be true about kids.
>> Okay.
>> So it makes sense that you can,
what the designers of OCL have done is
they've simplified the syntax by saying
you don't have to do all those ands
if we just have the constraints
listed there we can focus on
the ones that we want to focus on.
So, yes, in this case the signature
is going to be exactly the same as
what it was before.
>> So how would we express, or
could we express multiple
pre-and-post-conditions?
Is there an operation to string
some together or would we need to
make multiple constraint statements for
the same method.
>> So you can roll your own.
So let's say we had
three pre-conditions.
Okay, you could have them all in
the same constraint with 'ands'
between them, or you could have three
constraints, each with one precondition.
>> Okay.
>> Getting the same thing out of it;
the same thing on the post
condition side of things.
Likewise, an invariant is
something that must hold true.
If you have five invariants,
they all must hold true as if
you have 'ands' between them.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so that was the context in the
signature for checked out in this case.